[Music]
hey everybody what's going on it's
Monday and it's yeah time for our
paranormal palooza we're gonna go back
[__] do some uh
haunting episodes of the massive season
six all four episodes of Seasons yeah
Earth shattering season six it was just
like such a why bother season I mean I'm
not saying that the four episodes
weren't good because they are they're
entertaining they're well made I just
kind of feel like 60 60 yeah I guess
that was all they ordered because
they're like yeah we're canceling this
[__] but they didn't though because they
kept going like maybe that was when they
change dance I think that was when they
moved it maybe because didn't it started
on Discovery and then it went to
Destination America and it got sold a
couple times through companies that were
uh owned it but I think it was still the
same people producing it was the same
actors I think a lot of times yeah but
the ownership changed
that must have been that but I mean
that's what they usually do when they're
like yeah let's only make four episodes
that means they're canceling something
wrong but they must have like gone
through another thing because I think we
have season seven as well right I think
we got them all up to nine don't we well
we have season seven on physical media
yeah because I remember buying that for
you a long time ago and I think we have
season eight like in digital like I
think we bought that all right and we
might have bought I don't remember if we
bought nine or if we bought like a later
one like 11 or something I don't know
but we still have like a bunch that we
haven't done yeah you can buy them on uh
Amazon Prime yeah you can buy most of
the seasons like sometimes it says
currently not available it's got listed
but it just says not available you don't
know what the [__] up yeah it's like
they lost the the contract to sell it
yeah it's always a rights issue yeah
what would happen if you bought it and
then they lose the rights does it
disappear out of your catalog or do you
see it it shouldn't yeah it used to have
access okay yeah I mean it should you
should have it
but um but yeah so we do have
season six as far as it goes and uh this
one this was another uh blame the Goths
episode
the Goths brought in demons this time
it's always us they were killing cats
and everything yeah I was after that I
was just like no no goth worth their
assault would kill a cat yeah no yeah no
that's not I think they were heavy metal
kids if that or the whole thing's made
up this is another one where
there's not enough
well you know there's there's not enough
even in a lot of the other ones to know
for sure right it's just uh
there's not a lot of witnesses outside
the the event itself it's not as good as
Donnie Deckard where
wardens and and and and and and
[__] what do you call them damn cops
and yeah what do you call jail what the
jail do it's what they call them jail
dudes
that's Cruz no what do you call them
[__] prison guards yeah they saw it
you know it's like people from the
clergy saw it
so that's better when you have people
that are kind of outside the family
situation
because you call in a Paranormal
Investigator they're going to find some
paranormal [__] well yeah that's kind of
their whole bread and butter isn't it
yeah sorry murder Hornet just put three
little iterations of the famous icon so
that means that I have to do this
okay here we go where is that racquet do
it again we do it again but he did it
three times
[Music]
I guess because you have to click off of
it and then I don't know how the [__]
this works you know what I mean yeah
times just kind of like flying by the
seat of my pants here but yeah what's up
Tammy
hey everybody Sebastian's in there hey
everybody yep murder heard it said holy
[__] it's hot here I mean yeah it's hot
here too I went out and sat in my car at
lunch time and I was like oh my god I
think I'm gonna [__] die out here
yeah I had to go back in the people she
works with they bring dogs to work and
when a dog came in and just [__] on a
[__] corporate forever
yeah it was pretty good I had to clean
it up if I said the smell is [__]
bothered and it wasn't and it wasn't
just like a solid [__] either it was
like um runny diarrhea [__] people
bringing dogs right in the middle of the
carpet yeah
and I'm like yep I'm just gonna go in
here and puke for a minute yep thanks a
lot
so yeah and they actually let me go home
early because
because of the smell yeah well they
cleaned it but then like she came in it
was the owner's dog and she's and she's
kind of like well I'm gonna you know run
the vacuum like the cleaner and
everything like that she's like so yeah
and I don't want anybody in here when I
do it okay yeah so I was like okay well
that's fine I can leave because I kind
of feel like I'm gonna heave anyway and
like the woman the woman in the next
office kept like spraying [__] lice
on Febreze like everywhere and [__] like
that it was terrible I'm like and I'm
sitting there going like I have to put a
diaper on that dog I was like I can't
believe this is my [__] life oh my
God Yep this is like it's [__]
terrible we got approved for stream mate
we did just today it took a while
because
um I had I like a dumbass it was taking
a really long time and I was like and
finally I sent the message like why is
it taking so long because I'd heard that
it took a long time to get approval and
they were like oh well because you
registered as a couple but you didn't
put
um you know the other person's like ID
stuff up and I was like so I didn't see
any place where you could do that so I
just assumed that that would like I
would get approved first and then so I
uploaded his stuff and then I had to
upload like proof of address so I had to
put like a bank statement and [__] like
that and that took a couple of days but
today they said that we're approved so
we can yeah we're gonna start building
it's not gonna go live it's gonna take
time because we got to put stuff on it
we gotta set [__] up
the Twitter's got to be connected to it
so it's going to be another week
probably yeah but we might do some test
streams yeah we might do a test and see
like how it works yeah stuff like that
like maybe this week we gotta go in
there and see how everything works and
if I can make sure that are set because
we're gonna use a different set
I'm gonna make sure that that looks good
and figure out the fastest way to set
that up so we can convert between this
set and that's it
you know because this is a studio in
here yeah it looks totally different
that direction yeah if you turn the
cabinet that way it looks a lot better
it's got these evil curtains and [__]
evil curtains yeah red [__] Gothic
curtains and stuff I know I love those
and I got it and they were and they
weren't expensive either I got them on
Amazon they were like 18 bucks or
something they're like [__] satanic
Funeral Home
that's kind of my whole aesthetic yeah
with like an evil mirror
on the top it's got a skulls got RAB
horns on it and red candles and [__] and
dildos
yeah the dildos underneath it it's
[__] funny but see that's what I mean
we have all this kind of stuff in here
we're just asking for demon possession
yeah I guess we're not getting it at
least according to this yeah demons
don't show up maybe occasional
Poltergeist activity but Demon's scared
of me I think yeah
I'm the only demon around here that's
true yeah I don't think demons would be
like ah we can't even compete like that
like don't even bother this this post is
manned already
that's right yeah
yeah that's what it is all right so
let's go ahead and start with this case
Jim all right season six episode three
just called Black Magic yeah
so uh so yeah so the one bit at the
center of this a single mom named Debbie
guy now this takes place in a presumably
a small town because I've never heard of
it uh called ziegler'sville Pennsylvania
now she buys this house that's 150 years
old this happened back in 2009 I guess
like when she bought the house uh at
first so it's on like over an acre of
land like I said you know it's it's an
old house but um she had always really
wanted one like that and I guess even
though she's a single mom
um she had like been saving up like for
years and years and this is like her big
dream like to buy a house and she's just
like can't believe she finally did it
now moving in with her
she also has
a 28 year old son named David a 26 year
old daughter named Jody and Jody has two
kids she has a daughter that's five
named Zoe and a son that's seven named
Craig and then they also have this
random 17 year old
who I guess is not related to anybody I
guess like the way they he was just like
a family friend or someone that they
knew that they kind of like took in so
his name is Nick and like I said they
said he wasn't really related to any of
the other ones he was just like staying
with them
so Debbie actually works as a hospice
nurse
and you know like I said even though
sadly that job is not very well paid but
uh yeah but good job but it's a job well
I was saying that the fact that she was
able to save up enough money I don't
know how many years it took her to be
honest it probably took a really long
time
but so the second that they go into the
house David the older the Sun
he's like he thought the place was like
weird immediately like he said he walked
in and like the air felt really thick
like there was somebody already in there
you know what I mean so even like from
the beginning
so a few days go by and David starts
getting like more and more creeped out
now he didn't say this outright but what
they showed on the reenactment
was that he kind of heard like noises
like a little girl giggling
and then a red ball bouncing down the
stairs and I was like oh someone's seen
the changeling I guess because that was
kind of like a big plot point in that
movie if you haven't seen that
now because there's a little girl in the
house who's a five-year-old named Zoe um
he thinks that it's that but I guess
like he went up to investigate and she
wasn't there or something like that so
yeah so there's like creepy giggling and
balls coming downstairs and stuff like
that Ball's coming down yeah Ball's
coming downstairs
upstairs
[Laughter]
we're so mature but
we just can't let it go we can't say
balls it is what it is
she oh wait where dildo start flying
around we know the demons have showed up
still does your name on it over here uh
should we tell them about the about the
um
because we didn't tell him about the
about the the um what would we call it
no no I don't know
what we'll tell it we'll tell that story
on another show we'll put it on the side
track yeah yeah it was fun I mean it
wasn't funny at the time because it was
really we were trying to shoot something
we were trying and we had this [__] all
set up special effects went real
um
and if
we did it was [__] perfect it looked
great camera wasn't rolling it well my
phone camera had turned itself off
without me yeah noticing yeah and I was
like God [__] damn it it's like and
there was a thing where it's like I
couldn't really she was getting so mad I
was telling her to shut the [__] up
don't get mad
I mean you were getting mad yeah you
were making me madder though
because I told him I'm like oh you're
the only one allowed to get mad like
[__] look great he's a left to get
better but that's [__] great man it
looks real
it's better than real it did it looks
amazing and that's why I was so mad I
was like I looked up at the phone and I
was like [__]
it cut out a minute before the end yeah
like a minute or two because it got most
of it yeah
because I was like oh boys most of it's
there and then I was like oh [__] it
just like stopped in the moment because
my phone if you run out of memory like
it'll just stop recording without
warning you
so you know what I mean it's kind of
sucks but uh but yeah how do we get
distracted again oh oh balls down balls
downstairs oh and that's right Tammy
about the table for the dildos well I
was gonna say yeah I mean I did it did
occur to me when we were talking about
Paranormal Activity sometimes when we
talk about these shows I was like how
[__] funny would that be if like some
of the dildos started like floating
around in the background damn you've got
alien one oh alien ones over here big
[__] green Martian ones
werewolf ones we got we got everything
over here man
yeah we got some crazy ones we got a
couple yeah we got a couple new we're
gonna get crazier too
yeah I like The Crazy Ones they look
good on camera I don't like the
realistic one so much but um they don't
photograph very well yeah I like the
wacky ones yeah the wackier the better
yeah [__] crazy color with all the
crazy colors and stuff I just like them
crazy look at shapes because because
then I can coordinate my outfit with
whatever color it is that's how I know
like what I'm gonna wear you know what I
mean I was like well this one's like
kind of a Martian green so she had this
badass outfit she didn't take any colors
pictures of it in [__] white light I
was [__] upset about it it's I
thought I did some in white light no it
couldn't you couldn't see the whole
outfit well I can I can put it on again
it looked like a Barbie doll dress it
was it was pink
with pink fur that went around the boobs
made her boobs look huge it's got It's
like an anime character and the print
was like blonde anime girl like Sailor
Moon or something some [__] on the front
yeah like really big and she was wearing
a long black gloves up past her elbows
and long black boots to her up to her
knees with uh pink and black stripy
socks and she had pink braids yeah like
really long like well they were pink and
purple like like ombre yeah and she had
her little glasses on and her makeup
everything she looked great and shot it
and colored light lost all the color
I could have sworn I shot something in
white light though maybe I lost some no
I couldn't I didn't see any in white
light so you couldn't even tell his Pig
maybe I lost we just got to do it again
because I'm sure because I usually go
through all the colors yeah well all the
colors that look good because some of
the colors that we have because we have
the ring light and it's just like you
can't take like red the Selfies looks
pretty good we gotta you gotta get me in
there with with the camera and I'll take
full length photographs of that in white
light we'll set it up look at this I'll
set the lights yeah because like I said
I remember I you know I remember with
the outfit the outfit looks [__]
great man you need to wear that to a
club
blow people's minds because they've
never seen you in that color yeah you
look good and I never wear you should
have wore the blue contacts though that
would have made it well I was going to
but I was having problems with my eyes
and I thought I better not risk it next
time we do a [__] shoot though we wear
that out you get a good [__] big blue
contacts and set that off yeah and
actually I think the white hair would
look cooler with that
well yeah but I wanted to wear the pink
braids and to do the pink braids you
can't really wear a wig because you have
to have like ponytails or something like
that like to fasten them too
take that to the club and wear the white
wig yeah I thought it might look well
we'll get you a pink wig like the white
wig yeah because I don't have a pink one
no I have a couple red ones I have a
green one I have a purple one I have
like all I have a bunch of different
colors but I don't have a pink yeah it
was cute people
yeah not not usually something I would
ever wear but yeah it did look kind of
she looked like a Barbie doll it did
look kind of cool yeah yeah like a
Gothic Barbie doll yeah
um all right so yeah bouncing balls
that's where they were yeah so um so
yeah then Debbie is doing like the
renovations on the house or whatever and
starts having what appeared to be like
electrical problems I guess it was like
this lamp which would turn off and on by
itself all the time and it was just kind
of like flickering and all that kind of
crap
she also said that um over the next few
months like something that happened a
lot was like objects would move around
by themselves or would disappear she's
like you know you would turn you would
put something down and then you'd turn
around and like a second later you would
turn back and it would be gone she's
like that used to happen all the time
and she said that they also
um heard footsteps like really often
so here's Nick this 17 year old random
17 year old that lives in their house I
mean I'm sure they knew him he wasn't
random
but once they move into the house Nick
starts getting all Moody and distant and
rebellious
Debbie uh doesn't even hesitate to like
snoop through his [__] because I don't
know I'd be really I don't have any
teenagers but she's not related to him
is she and she's not related to him so I
would think I would be really mad if I
was a teenager and my parents like went
through my [__] or just some random
grown woman but yeah and so I'd be mad
if it was my parents much less if it was
just like some random woman I was living
with and maybe she could say well it's
my house and blah blah and you're acting
all [__] up so I have a right to like
look through your [__] but it's like
still I'm just I'm I'm a very um I'm the
kind of person that likes to respect
other people's privacy I would never go
through people's [__] imagine if this
was a 40 45 or 50 year old man going
through a rifling through a 60 year old
girl's [__] right that's kind of that's
gonna look sideways man if that always
just like gives me like puts a bad taste
in my mind I don't really like I I'm not
even really a big fan and like I said I
don't have any kids so maybe it's
different if you do have kids but I've
never really been a big fan of like
parents like going through their kids
[__] they're not gonna leave what they
find anyway
yeah and it's just kind of like I mean
unless the kid is like obviously a
serial killer or something like that
it's just like you know give them some
privacy for Christ's sake they're like a
person I don't know reading their love
letters and [__] right that's [__] up
it's like that's yeah you do it it's a
little perverse yeah and it's like and I
and I don't really like it so in this
you know she's just kind of like oh I'm
gonna go through his stuff because he's
acting different and I was just kind of
like holy crap so she starts going
through her [__] and he's pissed
obviously and she finds a book about
witchcraft uh oh not the Necronomicon
because that would have been funny but
because remember that episode that we
did the other day where they were
talking about and the guy has books on
the occult like the Necronomicon and I
was like okay you guys know that that's
not real right but um but yeah so they
find she finds a book on witchcraft and
also there's and this was kind of in the
um
in the image that I used for the
thumbnail she finds like a symbol
painted on the wall like it looks like
spray paint I guess it was supposed to
be a pentagram but it was real janky
looking pentagram gotta say unless it
was supposed to be some other kind of
symbol I didn't see it it looked
pentagram adjacent but it was just like
somebody was just like whatever yeah you
know what I mean I don't remember it's
like some half-assed like pentagram
and uh so she's kind of mad that he's
painting on the walls and also she has
these witchcraft books and stuff like
that so like I said he comes home and
catches her he's like hey you're going
through my [__] it's like you're making
a big deal out of nothing blah blah
now about this point Debbie
uh gets a real bad back injury at work
and needs surgery
so she actually has to like stop work on
the house obviously and she has to stay
on the ground floor of the house for
like a really long time uh you know
until she recovers because she can't
walk up into the stairs
now one night while she's downstairs she
said she saw an apparition
um like she woke up and she saw it so
this little girl it looked like very
clearly like early 1900s and she's like
what would happen I guess she saw her
more than once is what the implication
was so she said that she would wake up
and or she would open her eyes and she
would see the girl standing there like
at the end of the bed and she's like
sometimes she would close her eyes like
holy [__] there's a [__] ghost
standing there and then she would open
again it's like sometimes she'd be gone
but sometimes she would just have moved
like to the other side you know what I
mean that's what she said that's weird
so like I said I guess she had seen her
like more than once that's a weird
detail sometimes she's gone sometimes
she just moved yeah I thought that was
weird too that's like why I wrote it
down yeah now as weird as this sounds
Debbie said that she wasn't she's like
it was scary but she was actually kind
of relieved to see the ghost because for
a long time you know they thought that
there had been some weird paranormal
[__] going on like with [__] moving and
hearing footsteps and stuff like that
but they weren't really sure there was
nothing like definitive so like when she
saw the operation she's like oh well
okay I guess the shit's haunted that
proves it now so she's like so she
wasn't really all that scared of the
ghost at first because it was just a
little girl and it didn't look like
particularly malevolent or anything like
that
so about two months after this
um Debbie is recovered and she goes back
to work
and Nick God damn Nick he has a new
girlfriend who I thought they were
saying her name was Alicia but I think
they were saying Alicia let me get a or
a late or Alicia I think that's what
they were saying no I thought it was
Alicia but it's not and then I crossed
it out and wrote Alicia it was a weird
name
so the two of them
start doing like satanic [__]
um you know summoning a demon or it's
just Spirits or whatever the hell
and you know like I said it's a blame
the Goss episode so they're like oh he
started wearing black clothes candles
everywhere pentagrams all over
everything this was like really funny
because David who is the older son thank
you he was just I can't remember the
exact wording he used but I remember
like it cracking me up and he just was
like I don't like to see pentagrams all
over everything or something like that
like the way he phrased it was like
really funny to me I don't really it's
like it's just a it's it's fine it's not
it's not evil or nothing it's just a
pentagram on something just calm down
but yes it's like phantograms all over
everything candles everywhere yada yada
now David actually sees all of this like
sees all the [__] that him and his
girlfriend have like with all their
black clothes and pentagrams and whatnot
um but he's like well I'm not gonna tell
Mom about this because she's been
through enough and you know she's
doesn't really need to deal with it
so Nick and his girlfriend go to the
graveyard to start summoning Spirits
because David is like you know you guys
need to quit doing this in the house
like because I guess they were doing in
the basement or whatever
so they start going to the graveyard
like sneaking off now while they're in
there with their Ouija board and you
know what trouble that causes
um there's someone in the spirit and
they say they see like a shadow figure
in the cemetery that's just like a kind
of appears and it's just like standing
over there and they get freaked out and
run the [__] out of the cemetery and I
was like you guys
we're trying to like summon the spirit
and then one shows up and you get all
upset about it I was like what'd you
think was gonna happen I mean in real
life nothing would happen but I'm just
saying that it's like in the context of
what they were trying to do why would
they be upset that's what they were
trying to do hey it worked
okay but no they just got scared and
were like oh [__] bro run Scooby it was
like that kind of situation
so they run back to the house or
actually they drove back to the house
because they came in the car
but then when they get back to the house
and they go inside and they look out the
window and they saw the dude a
presumably the same dude or like the
shadow figure whatever standing outside
the house and they're like how the [__]
did he get here if he was just like
walking because we drove you know what I
mean
so they're like freaked out so they tell
David
about that and David looks out the
window and he sees him too now this
could have just been a real dude like
they're just a creeper whatever that was
standing there but you know it maybe
wasn't even the same person if indeed
they even saw anybody in the cemetery I
don't know but David said he saw him too
uh and the guy was like standing out
there in the yard basically like staring
at the house so David goes outside to
presumably like confront the guy and be
like hey how the [__] why the [__] are
you seeing in our yard but uh by the
time he gets out there the dude has
disappeared
so David tells Debbie about this his mom
and uh she don't want no Ouija boards in
the house she knows what that leads to
yeah
he's the Parker Brothers [__] up your
[__]
Parker Brothers Breeze the demons
and the father McKay he'd show up and
the warrants they're gonna have to do an
exmosism
[Laughter]
yeah yeah that's a redneck version
don't ask what I'm saying
it's like some [__] my dad would say
it does that's kind of what it reminded
me yeah I said that that's why it came
up I had this thing they called it
ecmosis
like turkey necks
you know how sometimes they put turkey
necks inside of you I swear
and put turkey necks in there it said no
they didn't dad
long story people my favorite part of
that story like whenever when you told
it to me the parts that made me laugh
the most was that you know and he
insists that he that his chest was
filled with turkey necks like after he
had open heart surgery yeah and Tom was
like trying to tell he's like no they
didn't put turkey necks in you um you
know and stuff like that and he's like
your dad said something like we don't
have to believe me that's your
prerogative yeah that's right so I don't
believe that that is that's your
prerogatory no
[Laughter]
no talking crazy like that he goes oh I
think he's got Hospital psychosis
yeah which is you know he was in there a
while yeah like yeah he'll be all right
he'll snap out of it yeah he'll snap out
of it he was like he he told his friend
go over his friend's name is goober
child and Fred true that they had
abducted him
yeah yeah and he says go go down to my
truck go get them go get my gun
you get your gun Tommy said yeah get my
gun bring it to me we're gonna shoot our
way out of here he was serious because
you got yours he goes yeah yeah
period of 1911 around with a [__] it
was just
goober carried a 1911 his whole [__]
life and it was that same one it was a
[__] singer made by Singer sewing
machine and it was totally this is World
War II era [__] and that thing's worth a
lot of money now but it's totally in the
rough there wasn't a bit of bluing on it
it was just metal bare metal
and it looked like it looked like
stainless but it wasn't it's just he
kept it in such good condition it was
just bare metal all the [__] bluing
had come off of it I think it was
actually parkerized when he first got it
when he was a kid
it was that same 45.
and he was [__] good man really good
with it competition shooter
just had a triggering job on it that was
it
uh no stock 1911 he carried it wherever
he went and didn't have a permit
Camp guy says I guess this is kind of in
reference to what we were saying earlier
about going through your teenager [__]
Camp guy said we always let our kids
have the most possible Freedom we could
sent them away to Camp travel without
parents uh and Camp I said my daughter
went to South Korea Italy and France
without parents by the time she was 13
or 14 years old that's pretty cool yeah
her dance trip went to South Korea and
they all danced at several public events
Tennessee clogging I just we did that in
school isn't that funny
even though I brought my my dad's side
of family is from Tennessee but I'm from
Florida
but yeah they we did clogging in school
I don't know why
I don't think everybody did but
we did I don't really know why
but yeah so this was my favorite part
about the Ouija board and this is the
part when it got to this point I mean
everything up to this is like pretty out
there too but it's like when it got to
this point like with the whole Ouija
board situation this is the part where
I'm starting to like smell [__] a
little bit well it smell [__] a lot
you know
so so yeah Mom says we don't want any
Ouija boards in the house
so Nick says okay we'll find you know
quit your bitching I'll put it away and
he kind of like knocks it off for a bit
but he just can't keep away from the
Ouija board man because that's how it is
it's like addictive so then he just
starts doing it again
now David the son he actually goes in
there and throws the Ouija board away
like he just puts it out in the trash
but it appeared apparently back where it
was because Nick was like what are you
talking about you threw it away it's
right here where I left it like on the
basement floor or something like that
and David's like [__] so I mean
as you would he thought oh well that
little [__] just went out there and dug
it out of the trash you know what I mean
so David takes it again gets in his
truck and drives however far I don't
know how far it was and just like
pitches it out in a field and like
leaves it but then a couple days later
it turned up back in the house again and
I was like no no it didn't stop it
um now this time he's like all right I'm
gonna figure this out so he turns it
over and he like scratches a big X like
on the back so he's like I'm gonna throw
it out this time so I'll know it's the
same one because I don't want to think
that maybe Nick is going out buying a
new one every single time and freaking
me out you know what I mean so I want to
make sure it's the same one there must
have been more than one yeah maybe Nick
had like a whole bunch of them he just
kept because that would actually if
you're if your parents or your
caretakers or whoever your Guardians
actually believed in that crap
um that would be a hilarious practical
joke I think well it might not be too
hilarious because if they really believe
they might like have you exercised or
something and you might die so maybe not
so funny but it would be really funny to
just go and buy a bunch of Ouija boards
and just like keep sticking them and
bills like oh my God it keeps coming
back I don't know what the deal is so uh
so yeah
so he marks it with a with an X and then
he throws it out again
but it comes back again and it's the
same one because it has like the X on
the back
at this point Debbie's like okay well
let me destroy it though he just threw
it out yeah he just threw it out man now
he's intercepting it in the garbage and
just bringing it back in the house well
yeah probably yeah probably Samantha
said Jenny your lip color looks Fab
thank you
yeah this is but this is probably my
favorite
um my favorite color it's Maybelline
matte ink but I can't remember what the
name of the color is
what I get all the time but I can't
remember what the name of the color is
and it's like too small the writing on
the bottom is too small for me to read
it anyway so I couldn't even check if I
wanted to
um so at this point Debbie's like all
right I'm gonna handle this so she's
like I'm gonna try and burn it which
you're not really supposed to do I mean
according to Ouija board Laura right
because aren't you just like releasing
all the demons then yeah isn't that what
they say yeah that's like the I was like
that's that's a bunch of [__] too
but like it yeah so she's gonna burn it
so she has like all of this kind of like
a little campfire trash burning
situation like out in the yard
and she puts it in the middle and like
Burns it but she's like but it wouldn't
burn like she went back and it's like
the everything else was burned but it
was just laying there like all [__]
pulled my [__] beer I was like yeah
I'll burn it like I said what is it it's
just breath board press board right I'll
burn it yeah she said it wouldn't burn
it just it was just sitting there in the
middle she tried to fight and it was
like completely fine diesel fuel and
[__]
you just like cut it up into little
pieces before diesel fuel you could blow
it up you could blow it up that would be
funny yeah you could like shoot it full
of holes you can do all kind of stuff
I just burn it yeah well she says she
tried to do that but it didn't work
heavier yeah
like a burnt metal all right yeah it's
like a little Ouija board yeah it's fine
uh so yeah so Debbie uh again snooping
through next stuff finds a bloody knife
in one of his drawers
and asks Nick about it and Nick and his
girlfriend Alicia or whatever her name
was say that they cast that they felt
really bad because they cast like this
really bad spell like to cause sickness
and death or something I'm like why
would you do that I don't really know
um but here was the worst part they said
that when they were casting the spell
they sacrificed a cat at which point I
was just kind of like you [__]
I hope the demons get you then
leave those kitties alone God damn it
so at this point Debbie's like yeah I
don't know what to do with this [__]
kid anymore so uh he's like I'm gonna
get she's like I'm gonna get him some
help uh so she this is how they put it
she puts him in a facility
that's how they put it which I was like
that's a nice way of putting it yeah
we're gonna put her and put him in the
[__] Hospital and we never hear about
Nick ever again so we don't know if he
ever recovered from his
Edge lottery or whatever it was that he
was doing
so because Nick is gone and now there's
like an extra bedroom so I guess prior
to this Jody's kids uh Zoe and Craig
have been sharing a room
but now they can have each other own
room so they moved Zoe the five-year-old
girl into Nick's old room
and pretty much the first night it seems
like Zoe sees a creepy little ghost boy
like outside the window like peeking in
at her like with a real mean expression
on his face
now she asks who he is and apparently he
says that his name is Jacob
so she tells her mom about this and
Mom's like okay well maybe if that room
is too scary for you then you can trade
rooms with your brother so Craig moves
into that room who is seven
a few nights after that Debbie checks in
on Craig the seven-year-old and finds
his blanket like pitched like behind the
dresser
and she's like what's this all about why
is your blanket way over here and the
kid says Jacob keeps pulling my blankets
off and he's like [__] with me all
the time well that seven-year-old kid
didn't save his [__] it'd be cool if
the kid seven-year-old kid did though I
know Jacobs keeps [__] with me he's
[__] with you he's [__] with me
for some reason like kids swearing is
like always really funny they don't
realize they're swelling I swear it
right like yeah if they're doing it it's
like oh I'm being so naughty it's not
funny then but if they're just like
talking like normal like I would then
then it's like really my parents busted
up I was in a stroller one time my dad's
trying to unlock the [__] door and he
can't find the keys it's dark and I go
God damn son of a [__]
I was in a stroller
I knew it was coming God damn son of a
[__]
that little baby Tom yeah I could talk
early and said all kinds of nonsense
see I would have just busted them yeah I
wouldn't be mad yeah it's just they're
just words that's right yeah I didn't
know what it was they they just laughed
yeah and I think most people I mean if
you had a kid and you were in public and
they started swearing I mean I think
most people would just think it was
funny I don't think anybody would be
offended or nothing
I just paired in what I heard right yeah
that's what I mean and that's what most
kids are doing I mean obviously they
hear in some place it's situational yeah
so um yes this ghost keeps [__] with
me said the kid
um so basically Debbie gets whigged out
by this because she's like okay well Zoe
the five-year-old she said that the
ghost name was Jacob that was peeking in
on her through the window and then in
the same room Craig also said that this
ghost was pulled his blankets off was
also named Jacob so she was like weirded
out that they both said the same name
because I don't know if they like
collaborated like or you know on the
name or anything like that but she
didn't think they did
so David decides he's gonna set up his
laptop with the webcam in Craig's room
like to see if he can catch like some
Paranormal Activity like happening
because the kid said it happen all the
time
now evidently although obviously they
didn't show this um for real on the show
uh he's watching the footage like while
the kid is sleeping and everything and
he sees the blanket like come off like
all ghosty like off of the kid's bed and
like kind of flies behind the what you
call it so he shows Debbie this video
and she's like holy crap like that's
obviously paranormal because you know I
mean the way they showed it on the
reenactment it like you know came way up
on the thing and like went over there I
don't know what it looked like in real
life it probably wasn't that impressive
so she decides she's gonna go to the
Historical Society to see if she can
figure out like what's going on
you know with the with the history of
the house if there's some kind of
information that would help them out so
what she finds out is that three people
have owned the house prior to her like
in the last 150 years which is pretty
impressive when you think about it now
several people did die in this house
including a little girl which maybe is
the one she saw earlier and a little boy
named Jacob
um they don't know what he died of
though that wasn't in the records They
said some of the uh some of the records
have been destroyed in a fire but she
did find uh that at least so she did
know that a kid named Jacob died in the
house at least according to the show
so Debbie at this point I guess she was
like a little bit older so she retired
from her job and David the 20 he was 28
or 29 however old he was and he decides
he's gonna move out because you know he
had a girlfriend and they were going to
move in together and um you know he's
kind of feels bad about leaving because
he's concerned about the family and
stuff but Debbie can't really afford to
move as much as she would kind of like
to because the house is creeping around
so she basically is like well I'm just
gonna try and like pray the ghosties
away that's just all you can do right
and so what she decides to do is while
Jody her daughter and her and the two
kids like her grandkids are away on
vacation or something
um Debbie decides she's gonna try and
you know go and read the Bible and all
that other kind of stuff like around the
house but apparently the entity gets
really mad uh grabs her scratches her
and pushes her down the steps so that's
uh you know just making the ghosties mad
is is what you're doing
so then she goes to the church for help
which that's always your first mistake
so the preacher comes in and he's doing
his thing and he's just like just comes
right in the door and he's like saying
all the prayers and stuff and apparently
Debbie got like violently violently ill
like you know because so I guess like
the demon was attacking her or whatever
but after he did his thing she said oh
you know the air lifted like somebody
opened a window blah blah house feels
normal for a few weeks she said after
the priest came
and so she actually invites some friends
over
now the friends it was a couple I guess
and the friend's husband man what a
chode that dude was I mean he was really
like Hamming it up for the show I guess
he's like I'm gonna be the biggest dick
I can be like on this [__] [__] so he
just comes in and he's straight up
because they're you know the the two
ladies are talking about like The
Haunting or whatever and he's like he
says something like you guys are idiots
like he says it like in pretty much that
tone I'm like well that's nice I was
like you come in my house and drink my
[__] beer because he was drinking a
beer and call me an idiot and like
[__] laugh at my face about the
[__] paranormal struggles I'm having
so you know what I mean [__] off you're
not invited anymore
so um so then he just starts going
around the house going into oh are the
ghosts in here and he's like I said he
was being like a real [__]
so he's like challenging the spirits I'm
guessing but then he goes down to the
basement like ooh it's so scary blah
blah and then he's like taking pictures
like all around and apparently one of
the pictures that he took had this
really scary like ghosty face in it like
this man's face and he was like oh [__]
and I'm like yeah what did you think was
gonna happen like I said oh big man now
you [__] probably peed yourself
okay you know I'm just saying
I just yeah so well like I said he was
really like overselling he's like how
big of an [__] he was I don't know
what he was really like
so yes there's like a creepy demon face
what was like a man's face and it wasn't
really a demon face
so Debbie calls in a paranormal
investigation team uh the main guy's
name Bill Cook uh who I guess was a
former cop and now he has like an
investigation I can't remember what the
name of the group was
now while the team was there the first
time they did have the basement door
which uh slammed on its own and they
also have this one woman named Carrie
who is you know the psychic or the
sensitive or whatever and she says oh
the basement feels uh weird and there's
like a really heavy negative feeling
down here and apparently I don't know if
anybody told her any of this [__]
beforehand but the show made it seem as
though she just came and was like is
this where Nick sacrificed a cat you
know what I mean like so it was almost
like she was getting divinely getting
that information but they might have
told her that ahead of time I'm not sure
so but on the show they made it seem
like she just came in and knew that [__]
have you worn these glasses on the show
yet I don't know about on the show I've
worn them in some yeah you guys don't
want to show you another pair of glasses
that I got I mean I might have these are
the ultra nerdy glasses yeah because I
think I've we said something about Ultra
herty look how cute those are yeah wear
those because those are different now
get a different look that fits that
those fit that wig better yeah yeah what
do you guys think of those glasses you
can drop it in the comments I really do
like this yeah I think that's cool I'm
trying to get her trying to get her
readers
like that
look at that these look really good on
her but I can't but they're not readers
they're not readers so I can't see like
I'm trying to get readers like that I've
been looking all over the Internet for
oversized round readers they're only
come in
just cosmetic
but they're just they're they're not
[__] no magnification at all what is
it you use 1.25
yeah I probably I think it's 1.5 1.5 or
two or two I'm getting Blinder yeah
as the days go on we need to confirm
that so I can get on the internet keep
searching I'm trying to get something
like this is readers Tammy said are you
gonna try and burn those evil dildos
[__]
[Laughter]
they're really cool I'm gonna get some
we got a martian one over there Tim he's
got your name all over it this is not
even circumcised
it's green it also it also glows in the
dark yeah which I didn't realize until I
came in the office like in the morning
one time and I was like oh look at that
it's green it was like glowing yeah and
it's actually like much you can't really
tell like but it's like really Vivid
yeah it's [__] like like neon green
yeah and like I said it glows in the
dark too which I didn't yeah and it's
not human it looks like a caterpillar
Kinda Yeah it's like it's got all kinds
of weird [__] on it yeah all sorts of
weird bridges
yeah Julian Pope said the cat sacrifice
made me mad me too yeah like this
episode I was just like no goddamn
because you know how mad I get when I
mean if you guys watch my movie reviews
or book reviews or something like that
anytime like a dog or cat gets killed in
a story I get like really weird
uh yeah Camp guy said I like the round
glasses yeah I like them too Samantha B
said I watched a reseller or trash
picker that found a Ouija board in the
trash took it home people were freaking
out in the comments I guess so like oh
my god do you know what kind of stuff
you can bring it's like it's fine it's
just like I said it's just
I don't get this whole thing about Ouija
boards man like everybody being scared
of Ouija boards it's something tangible
they can call upon and use it as a damn
um uh as a prop in a story yeah that's
what I think and you know they're made
by Parker Brothers
and when Parker Brothers introduced them
they didn't really even have a kind of a
long history of like Paranormal boy or
like a mythology that kind of came later
it was more like Parker Brothers
invented that mythology they did I think
to a large extent yeah so
all this stuff about what you can and
can't do with one you can't burn one you
can't this is all [__] that was made up
later yeah but people in the spiritual
spiritist movement
and they
they did things what you'd call they did
things um that I would call pulling out
of the ass
they would pull a thing out of their
asses constantly because they were doing
seances
Seance was a hustle back in the
Victorian era before television and even
theater wasn't that big you could go to
a seance and get a girl to pull
something out of Coach yeah in a dark
room which when are you ever gonna see
that in the Victorian era yeah they
called it egoplasm other than maybe at a
whorehouse yeah but like I said it was
just kind of like I'm sure that was like
a kink for some people yeah I'm pretty
sure it was and uh there were some I
heard some skeptical like um
what do you call it um
critiques of some of the real famous
mediums and and they were like yeah
she's pretty she's real good at
making all this phenomenon up here
we tried to catch her but we know she's
faking and we also know she's turning
tricks at these [__] events
because she you know what I mean the
woman in question was also like a
prostitute or had a history of it
and so it was like a Carney type yeah
event you know
like yeah she'll
summon the spirits and then you know
give you a hand job afterwards so you
know I'm [__] it was a it was a
[__] Full Spectrum Entertainment man
she was
what they call multimedia yeah that was
the time well like I said that's pretty
cool you get to go and like it's all
creepy you see the dark room with
candles and then like like I said you
get some lady to like pull stuff out of
her vagina yeah you know the glows and
whatnot yeah and then you know maybe
they'll be like I have to reach over
there
and then she can say that it's the
spirits doing you just did it your wife
was sitting right next
[__] your wife didn't know
so the medium's like it wasn't me like
it wasn't me the spirit the spirit gave
you that gave you that yeah you're
tipping like crazy
[Laughter]
I love the ending
I was very happy very happy oh my God we
should do whatever we should do a
straight we should do a stream eight
we should do a video like that well we
should do a video like that it's like a
seance oh that would be super fun
I love Seance [__] I do like I know it's
all fake but I'm fascinated by the
lengths that they went to to fake some
of the [__] like I love all the kind of
stuff about
um like all the weird [__] that they
built like like I said most of the time
they just had phosphorus and pain they
just like stuck it up their cooch or
whatever but they had like all these
little secrets these little things that
they would like little tricks that they
would use and it's like I'm fascinated
by that kind of stuff I love all the
iconography about that I just love all
of that in case you guys know what we're
talking about pulling things out the
couch they had this phenomena called
ectoplasm
and they would try to photograph it and
they would say that they saw it and [__]
like that and really all it was is gauze
roller yeah like cheese claw cheesecloth
and they'd roll it up in a way that kind
of like a magician would do it and they
would hide it in certain areas of like
their clothes or whatever and they'd
pull it out and they might have a little
cut out photograph of somebody in there
they take a picture in the middle of the
[__] for Seance and then there's yeah
the ectoplasm came out of my mouth
well one of the places they'd hide the
ectoplasm if it was a female was in the
cooch they'd pull the ectoplasm out and
[__] skirt and it was happening in a
dark room so you couldn't see you
couldn't see or do it well she's just in
there yeah it was but it was just where
the hiding place was because they were
producing a lot of ectoplasm and then it
would mysteriously disappear because it
had people in the room helping yeah that
was another thing yeah like they would
usually have like black bodysuits on
right with like little fishing poles or
like fishing lineup yeah I need help
with all the like little horns floating
around and all that kind of yeah
yeah but it was just like gauze and
cheesecloth and stuff but like some of
the Witnesses were real believing they
were like it was strange when the
ectoplasm came out it had a very Earthly
smell to its body like a smell to it
yeah [__] yeah a real player would
have known what that smell was yeah it's
like he's like no yeah yeah okay
I know where this has been yeah
but yeah see like I'm fascinated by that
kind of stuff I love all of that kind of
stuff and I was gonna say when we were
talking about like Ouija boards I
actually just bought a wallet that has
like a Ouija board on it like on one
side it's actually really cool looking
and then um
the little uh clasp thing with the chain
is the little planchette it's like it's
pretty neat I think I got that on uh she
and now that I'm thinking yeah and it
was only like yeah like crazy well we
got a [__] I got oh I basically
dollars worth of clothes for like 200
bucks yeah I basically got a whole
entire wardrobe I've been worn all this
[__] that I haven't even had time to
wear all the [__] that we bought yet we
probably it wasn't 200 bucks we probably
spent about 300 350. in probably yeah
maybe like over the time and we got
retail what would have been about a
thousand dollars probably I have yeah
yeah because you got me some pants yeah
too and like three of the pairs came and
they all look really cool and then
there's two more videos like on the way
yeah one of them is a Dia de los Muertos
[__] pants yeah we've got cartoons
from like
Mexican girls and [__] skeletons
cartoons they look good
yeah like in a Mexican type code red red
and black
and then a lot of skull pants and Gothic
pants and they're all bell bottoms they
look really good
stretchy tight bell bottoms yeah you
wear them with big old [__] platforms
are they good well the one pair that I
have um one is a peg leg I think in it
well the one pair that's bell bottoms I
definitely have to wear big platforms
with those because they are way long
because like my legs are really short
yeah but the other ones fit good but
those ones are they fit good but they're
just like they're for really long
they're really for there for really tall
people or really high platform boots
really high platforms I think so but I
have a high platforms yeah so that's
fine you probably could have taken a
size smaller maybe because they are
really stretchy well they were mediums
yeah but I mean they can't I mean they
fit good at the top it's just that
they're a lot real long yeah and the
thing about it is even if you got a
smaller size they'd probably be the same
thing they probably long yeah
um whereas Tammy said well that
glow-in-the-dark dildo probably put that
ectoplasm up her vagina yeah that's
probably how she is yeah yeah put it
right up in uh what I call Nature's
pocketbook
[Laughter]
you know you can hide all kind of stuff
in there
well that was another thing you were
telling me about that about that uh that
that porn girl that um puts all the
footballs and stuff up her butt oh you
talk about how kinky Joe yeah and uh and
I was saying to myself here's this is
you can tell I'm a girl because this is
the first place that my mind went to I
was like man I bet she never has to
carry a purse anywhere she can just
carry everything up
it's like wait where are my keys and
then she like [__] that was the first
place my mind went I was like I don't
know coming back I don't know what's
wrong come back from koiwan and we
somehow got on the [__]
subject to [__] extreme penetrations
I bring up on King and Joe and tell her
what that girl does for a living Jenny
was just [__] amazed I haven't shown
her to you though just showed her
picture of her yeah but yeah you were
gonna show me some of the videos and
then we forgot a girl can put her arm
inside of her up to the elbow and wave
to you and you can see her hand in her
abdomen yeah and she's like wait and
they're laughing it's like it's not even
a big deal
acrobat I was like see everybody's good
at something I was just like damn
football footballs
it just insane things you know and she's
some Eastern European chick from she's
from a while back she's not new
but and she's and to look at her you'd
go
she's skinny and scrawny
there's something about her face you
look at her face though and you go yeah
she'd be able to do it that's what job
said he's like yeah there's he's like I
can't really put my finger on it but she
looks like exactly the kind of person
that you should do that when you be like
yeah she could stuff whole footballs up
her butt yeah yeah and I was like I was
like I know exactly what you mean yeah
yeah yeah yeah exactly you look at her
you go yeah she'd be able to do it see
these are the kind of conversations not
even it's we don't have to be on the
show we have these conversations all the
time it's like that like I don't know
how this thing ends up like that but
because it's like it's funny when we
were talking about doing our other
projects and [__] that were coming up on
streambating everything some of our
regulars are like shocked and I was like
you haven't been paying attention to the
show you don't really know us
we're crazy we know a lot of crazy
people and [__] it's all fun and games
though we don't take we're like circus
people we don't really can't take any of
that person there's limits you know yeah
I was like I'm not gonna do any [__]
thing yeah it's just but it is like a
good yeah we are kind of like circus
people yeah yeah you know
you know full-blown full-blown Studio
porn and [__] multi millions of
people per year and [__] sugar sugar
in and sugar daddy in a sugar baby in
and escorting and [__] no no that we're
not that kind of people
but just
professional style independent stuff
just between me and her
maybe like some chick we know or
something maybe
but you know
nobody else yeah like I said I don't
want a bunch of randos yeah there's no
such thing my buddy was in like man hey
all these random people there's no Rando
people even you know even like
some of the [__] like the people that
want to [__] with us are all our exes
yeah like couples that we dated like I
asked girlfriend and the guy that I
introduced her to that's now her
husband's trying to [__] with us you
know just we're getting invited to like
we've always been like invited to like
the swingers clubs and [__] yeah to go
hang out with our exes
[Laughter]
so
it's a weird scene it's not when it's
not weird it's not weird when you know
these it's not weirdos yeah it's not
weird they're all from the god scene and
they kind of do that on the down low and
it's like a little underground version
of that but we know them all so it's not
as it's not as weird when you know them
you're like oh look of course yeah of
course yeah it's like yeah if we were
drunk and awesome [__] yeah and some of
them are porn stars and some of them are
like just online content creators and
stuff which is that's not a porn star
we're an online content creators yeah
pornstar works for a studio and they got
management [__] today you'll do this
and this and this and this and he didn't
really have a choice in it you know
yeah if you want your career to go and
you're going to do this and that yeah I
mean like I said the whole point the
whole fun of it for me was like doing it
independently so we could just do what
we do what you want wanted yeah I don't
want to be it's like you know if I I
already got to do a bunch of [__] I
don't want to do because you know if you
have like a regular job you have to do a
bunch of [__] you don't want to do like
we're planning on we want to do like an
outside shoot and we're gonna um shoot
outside but it's hot and we wanted to
like make a day of it and like have a
picnic yeah and then shoot porn yeah and
be it her and we we're gonna plan it all
out yeah the outfits and everything so
so wait wait until it cools off a little
bit yes because it's like 100 degrees
outside right now but I'm just like I
walk outside and I'm like nope
yeah nope yeah
but uh yeah so where were we oh yeah um
so so the the psychic lady goes down to
the basement and they the show makes it
seem like oh she knew that that was
where Nick and like sacrifice the poor
little kitty cat and the cat's like
don't involve me in this I didn't do
anything
and uh the woman says oh well if they
sacrifice an animal or a person you know
a baby or something uh they're like that
obviously makes it a lot harder to get
rid of the entity that they summoned
because that's how [__] works I guess
so upstairs there's another member of
the team and they're up there doing EVPs
or whatever the hell and I guess like a
door like slams open and close like by
itself
and then they're taking photos like in
the room like by the door that just
opened by itself and I guess allegedly
the photo that they took like captured
the little girl ghost and they showed it
to Debbie and she was like holy [__]
that's the little girl I saw or
something like that like I said I don't
know if that's true or not but that's
what they said oh uh before you go into
this could you guys give us a uh do us a
favor and go ahead and press that like
button before you leave
just click it yeah we only got like one
thumbs up nobody likes us yeah they
don't like it'll help us out not really
yeah yeah
um but yeah so the team does that they
[__] around or whatever and then they
leave and they're gonna go analyze the
data and like you know then we'll be
back and then there's like this whole
big thing where Debbie gets the whole
like Exorcist treatment right like she
gets [__] attacked in her bed like
the bed shaking like a dark figure
apparently like stand it over there
going or whatever like the whole [__]
deal like no there's no pea soup vomit
or nothing like that but like the bed
was shaking and she was like being
rattled all around and everything
so the day after that Debbie's like okay
well [__] this I'm gonna move into
another room she doesn't like that room
so the paranormal team comes back for
like the second assessment or whatever
um and they're like at this point you
know and they always kind of say this
too like the psychic lady she's like
well the ghost could actually be you
know the actual ghost that they appear
to be like the two kids that died in the
house or they could be the entity the
evil entity the demon whatever it is
like pretending to be that so you know
but we won't really know which one it is
so a few days later they decide they're
all going to do a cleansing
and Debbie does a thing where she goes
around like this is my house and you
don't belong here and you're not welcome
hearing Vlad of black and uh she says
she feels kind of better after that
and so the activity stops after they do
the cleansing for a while they said it
stopped for like six months
and then six months later David who
would remember like moved out to move
him his girlfriend he comes by like to
help out with some kind of like
renovation [__] or whatever that was
going on the house and he finds in the
house a
Ouija board which uh apparently there
wasn't supposed to be a Ouija board in
the house anymore he was like oh no it's
starting again you know what I mean like
the [__] thing brought the Ouija
board back
but I don't know why that's so funny to
me but it is uh so yeah so they find
another Ouija board and they're just
like [__] this it's like starting all
over and Debbie is just kind of like
well there's really like nothing to be
done it's like look we've already gone
to the church and got the blessing [__]
we already got like the paranormal
investigators and they came into the
cleansing and it didn't do jackets like
it did something for six months and then
like the Ouija board popped out and it's
like starting all over again so she's
like well she can't afford to move
now a few weeks after that
um I guess there's like a door slamming
like upstairs like she's standing
downstairs and then like the door at the
top of the landing like slams by itself
and then she said she felt a hand like
inside her chest like squeezing like it
was trying to then she like collapsed to
the floor or whatever I'm assuming she
was just having a heart attack but she
did like attribute it to uh the ghost
although she said she went to the ER and
they couldn't find anything wrong with
her so I guess it wasn't a pain like
maybe it was a panic attack but um but
yeah she said it felt like the ghost was
kind of like like right inside her chest
like that
so at this point she's like all right
well the shit's getting dangerous like
this motherfucker's trying to kill me or
whatever so her uh daughter and
grandchildren still lived in the house
so at this point she's like you guys
need to move out like it's not safe here
anymore so she like sent them away she's
like she's bummed out about it obviously
because now she's in the house alone but
she's like I didn't want anything bad to
happen to them so she made them move out
for their own safety so she puts the
house up for sale
um and basically ha is stuck there until
the house sells and the house had not
sold at the time that they made the show
so basically she's living in the house
by herself putting up with all these
paranormal Shenanigans until someone
bought the ship so basically like the
the voiceover guy is like she's
remaining in fear until you know until
she sells the house I'm sure this house
has probably been sold by now because
this was like what when did this the
season six I think was 2000 2010 13.
well no but the story started in 2009
okay but um the show come came out in
2013. I think season six was two they
match in 2010 at one time in there and I
was like okay that's when this was
2009 was when they was when she bought
the house okay
but like I said the show came out in
2009 that's right in 2013. you're right
so in so whenever they made the show
whenever they produced the show the
house was apparently up for sale but had
not sold yet so she was living in it by
herself and still hearing weird voices
and having all this Paranormal Activity
but just having to like kind of put up
with it because she couldn't afford to
move because she had like put all of her
life savings into the house so she was
kind of stuck so I don't know what
happened to her subsequently but that
was how they ended up like nothing was
resolved yeah and and to tell you what
you know you guys
you guys know that you know Jenny and I
have both seen paranormal phenomenon
me more than her
uh math Mountain Poltergeist uh had
a body experiences at a near-death
experience
I've never seen anything that quite fits
this pattern that what they're talking
about that's not Poltergeist
if it happened I'd have to see it myself
to believe it
not saying it didn't happen it's just
I've never seen anything like it
and that's with a lot of these
[__] exorcism type cases and demonic
suppose I've never seen anything that I
would could call a demon and a
poltergeist is scary as [__]
and physically moves more objects than
what the what they're describing here
and seems stronger
so I don't know
it's easy to invent stories anybody can
invent a story when you see it you
believe it
I'd have to see this myself to believe
it
yeah I don't I mean to me like I said
I'm not a big believer in like seeing
apparitions and all that kind of stuff
but the thing that had the biggest whiff
of [__] in this to me was the was
the whole reappearing Ouija board thing
yeah they seemed very sincere about it
though it could be a misidentification
he might have had multiple Ouija boards
or he was finding the Ouija board in the
garbage and bring it back into the house
it's an easy easy explanation yeah and I
mean that seems the most likely scenario
to be honest
the idea that a demon is bringing it
back in using paranormal four so let's
sneak it with the Ouija board under his
arm in the box and everything
probably know this could have been just
kind of a run-of-the-mill haunting and
then the people are kind of blowing it
into something that it's not and then
there's a bunch of misidentification
misidentifications and you know yeah you
threw the Ouija board out but I went out
and got it and brought it back in you
know what I mean it could have been and
then pretended that it's like what it
was just here because like I said that's
what I would do if I was an [__]
teenager like that right and like I said
that would be a really good prank if
your parents actually did believe that
Ouija boards were real like it really
worked I've never seen what you know
with I think Steve Miller would call
what he would call that a demon a
demonic
demonic haunting yeah
I've never seen one he says they're real
but I've never seen one
I'd have to see it
yeah I mean so yeah
because like you said there's the reason
that I'm like so skeptical of the most
paranormal [__] is just because there's
so many rational explanations for some
of the stuff that happens that that you
really have to like go through all of
those rational explanations before you
can pause it that it's a supernatural
explanation like you said reappearing
Ouija boards it's like that could be
it's much more likely yeah that the kid
was just digging it out of the trash or
had more than one then it is like
positing this whole oh the ghost or the
demon is bringing it back or the mixture
of two he had two one got thrown away
and he brought the other one and then he
threw that one away and he went out and
got it right so you know he had two
Ouija boards so you saw it three times
so something real simple like that
um doesn't mean that the other
phenomenon didn't happen it's just that
they're conflating
they're they're piling
misidentifications on top of Haunting or
on visual sightings or something else
you know an apparition
see that's another thing is I've never
seen that type of a humanoid Apparition
I've seen some blue haze and round balls
or like blue haze
but that was in a poltergeist
environment
years later when I got out of the army
me and a buddy of mine moved into a
place in Boston we've talked about it
before it was a bad house everybody that
[__] came in there with us [__]
was very uncomfortable in that house
there was something in that house felt
like it was watching you
and it was bad I felt like it attacked
me but I never saw anything yeah
it was just attacked attacked by waves
of fear and emotion
felt like it was spinning around me like
it was getting ready like it was so over
this is just one it did this only once
it was so oppressive that I was nearly
losing Consciousness that's how intense
it was had to fight to keep conscious
and that was the only thing it did but
it wasn't physical
and it never moved anything
and I never heard anything and never saw
any apparitions just feelings
it wasn't just me it was other people
too just a bad house never got down to
it and that's the thing you can never
really prove something like that because
it's so subjective yeah like everybody
just like ooh I don't like it in here
like everybody feels weird about it but
see that that could be
um you know maybe there's some kind of
like low-key like [__] gas leak in
there or maybe there's something like
there's some other kind of like physical
things making everybody feel like that
her girlfriends would come and spend the
night and we'd have to walk them down
the hallway to the bathroom so they'd go
to the bathroom I had to wait outside
for them they were scared
yeah I don't think I've ever been in a
house they didn't want to walk down the
hallway by ourselves yeah I mean my
grandfather's house that I lived in you
know off and on like when I was growing
up was creepy but I was never that
scared like that I couldn't go down the
hall it was a big three-story it was a
big three-story Victorian house that
layout didn't make any damn sense in the
house and had a basement and it was over
a hundred at that time that was in the
90s mid 90s it was over like 130 140
years old at that time
and it was just a bad house
but you can't put your fingers on it you
know
and man when it got cold it got [__]
cold as [__] in there it wasn't
insulated well
and winter come you were just [__]
deathly cold in there
and uh when wind would [__] blow you
the whole house would just kind of
[__] you could feel the whole house
just shift because it's wood you know
and it felt like [__] wind was
blowing through the house you know which
it may have been little cracks in there
I don't know
but there was just you couldn't sleep
well you had nightmares in there
a [__] weird Visions me I just kept
having visions of starving masses of
starving puppies stuffed into all the
damn pipes going down to [__] water
[__] up I wonder what that's going
down into the basement a basement filled
with [__] starving puppies and [__]
and uh just it was just a bad house I
mean what a [__] up image I kind of
want to like use that in a story yeah
the pipes were just jam-packed full of
starving [__] crying puppies
that's I just I wonder what that
represented I don't know
I mean I'm not saying that dreams
necessarily have to represent anything
sometimes they're just like [__]
random but one of the closets had a
[__] false back in the closet and
pulled it out and [__] once I pulled
it out oh [__] I closed it when God Eric
said Eric Matt found a secret door he's
like what we talked about as a dude
check this out and I showed it to him he
was [__] too and opened it up is at
the very top floor
and I go dude get a flashlight
and he went back and he got a flashlight
I was and while I was waiting for him by
that [__] door open just that
blackness in there I was [__] getting
scared man for him to come with it come
back of that flashlight
I shown the flashlight and it was just a
roof and it was just a little triangular
triangular space about two feet
wide and about four feet tall
and you can see the rungs of the [__]
wrong select floorboard type things you
know what I mean you could step from one
board to the next when I shown the light
on one side it went all the way down the
length of the house and there was
nothing in there I've shown the light
the other way and there was nothing all
the way down at the end there was a
little box
cardboard box
and [__] go dude look there's a box
back there and he's [__] oh [__] it's
like this is like the start of every
horror movie ever we should not go and
it wasn't that way
and he's like go get it
you go get it yes it's all right we're
both the [__] out of the [__]
101st we're like Airborne Airborne
[__]
infantry we're like okay I'll go get it
so I'm going down there and I'm [__]
dodging the roofing nails so I can going
from one rung to the next and I see that
[__] box there I'm going [__] man and
[__] Eric's [__] with me he goes tell
me what the baby looks like yeah I would
have I would have said severed head but
yeah it did baby that would have been my
second no it's [__]
reached down there and opened up the
[__] box when they put the flashlight
in there it was empty just had a [__]
uh newspaper in there
a single sheet of newspaper so I just
brought it back
see I wonder how that ended up in there
like what used to be in there I don't
know and the sheet of newspaper had a
date like back in the 70s
hmm yeah interesting there wasn't even
like a blood stain on it or anything I
was an empty box with a single sheet of
newspaper see that's in a way that's
almost more intriguing because you're
just kind of like how why is that there
then I don't know
it was something that something had been
packed in that box
at one time and then somehow the the Box
got pushed I think they were using it as
storage yeah and that was and that was
just like and they just left it that was
empty so they left it yeah everybody's
making like seven jokes like what's in
the box what's in the box
ERS had in there I think one time they
had a bunch of storage stuff in there
yeah it was like a crawl space yeah it's
probably not that mysterious no but see
well I'm a horror writer so it's like
anytime something ambiguous happens like
that I always like unspool like a
terrible Horror Story about it because
it's that's that's the fun part when I
showing that flashlight all the way down
there and saw that box man [__] I was
like oh [__] and he sees it it's like
Eric sees it he's like and he said this
is like the same thing serious I would
[__] or break if I looked down and be
like it's like I really want to know
what's in there but I really really
don't at the same time he's like go get
it I'm not gonna go no
[__] [__] I was like yeah all right
yeah
see that kind of [__] like I said that
kind of [__] creeps me out because it's
just like ambiguous and the fact that it
was empty it was empty I don't even want
to say I mean obviously it'd be creepier
if you felt like a dead baby in there
like a mummified what else what he was
saying you know I was he was going on
he's gonna be a baby in it but in some
ways
I don't know in some ways it's almost
it's pretty creepy too that it was just
like empty I think it did I think it had
something in it yeah but what they did
was is they condensed the load they took
whatever was in there and put it in and
put it in my bigger box the box that was
next to it right that way they didn't
have to carry two boxes that was the
last box so they just left the other box
because they had to walk across those
rungs right you know you're in a fun
time they were like two by fours and you
had to only walk on the on the two inch
section and there was like foot and a
half in between them all insulation and
you had to walk across those there
wasn't any floor
but they would put boxes yeah in there
strategically
you know what I mean in between the rugs
yeah so they were standing there so they
had like in our old Attic in our old
house which didn't really have a proper
floor either yeah uh And Justice For Me
said I would have expected that
Necronomicon yeah what would yeah what
would you have done if you'd have looked
in that box and it was like the this the
[__] skin book from the Evil Dead the
real
quick but if it was if it was the B
Dalton version
yeah then it wouldn't be a little Signet
you know what I mean [__] see now
like if I if we ever move out of the
house now I kind of want to do that like
I just want to leave like a box just in
a random area for somebody and I'll just
put like some creepy [__] in there but
like some creepy but like ambiguous [__]
yeah that would be like a really good
prank and then somebody would find that
and like [__] wet himself that
monster dildo in there
yeah and that's it that's just that one
thing yeah why is this in the Box they
would like they would lose sleep like
wondering like why that was like that
see that would be like [__] hilarious
well see it's just like the whole Ouija
gag yeah where you have more than one
Ouija board and just like stash them
around the house so like people think
that they're returning that's funny as
[__] I'm gonna have to do that Etc I
don't know anybody that believes that
they're real really but if I did that
really wholeheartedly believed it yeah
that would be a great prank yeah
Tammy said find somebody's old [__] pot
yeah that would be my luck I'd look in
there and [__] yeah all right so I
guess we're gonna wrap it up for the
evening because it's getting about that
time yep so uh yeah so hopefully you
guys enjoyed this uh you know journey
into the Paranormal and you know all of
the other
tangents that we took so uh the next
show is gonna be the main show obviously
and that's Wednesday night and this
should be a fun one this was actually a
recommendation by you guys and it wanted
to pull by a very large margin so on
Wednesday night we're going to be
talking about flat earthers so that
should be really fun well I don't know
if um I haven't decided if we're gonna
talk about like I might get into like
the background of like historical
flatters kind of stuff but I kind of
feel like it'd be more interesting to
talk about modern flat earthers and I
found on 2B
I think it originally was on Netflix but
it's on 2B now for free and there is a
documentary about modern day flat
earthers and I think it's called behind
the curve behind the curve is I think
it's what it's called like I watched
like the first five or ten minutes like
on my lunch hour today and I was like oh
that looks really good so I'm gonna have
to like watch that like tomorrow or
something like that and see uh
and see what that's all about but uh but
yeah so I'm kind of looking forward to
getting into that
nonsense so that should be like really
fun so yeah so that's gonna be the show
on Wednesday night
so hopefully you guys can join us for
that I don't know if Tom just went off
to the bathroom or if he's gonna like
come back and like say goodbye but if
he's not then I don't know I'm not gonna
wait around oh you are coming back yeah
oh okay so I don't well I didn't know
because I was like I was like should I
end because he's like I didn't know if
you just like walked off without saying
anything well you know I was like you do
if she's if she's off by the time I come
back then it's over it doesn't matter
yeah it doesn't I'll be on here we're on
here for many times many times a week
that's true yeah it's it's not like
anybody's gonna be like where are they
yeah where did they go yeah it's like
you know probably the rest probably most
of the people are just like Jesus but
what are you people gonna throw away
you're still at this
but yeah please get out of my shirt but
yeah so uh so hopefully you guys can
come by on Wednesday so have a good rest
of your evening tonight and have a good
day tomorrow and we'll see you guys
again on Wednesday night good night